elephantiasis is a disease spread
through mosquitoes worldwide over a
hundred and twenty million people are
infected and the largest number of those
are in India it's symptoms are
unmistakable if anti asus is untreatable
but in fact the opposite is true and in
India the race is on
to eradicate it forever rather than
cities the largest rates of infection
are in villages but there are people on
the frontlines like Sheila and Pratt
EEMA who both work for the Ministry of
Health and who go by foot village to
village to help their days start
extremely early as they head out to meet
and treat people across northern India
malaria is DNA catimor akihabara manage
a group in a or de Vaca p.m. the attenti
kolkata hedonic a Teletubby nee is
america could convince Evonik arrange
basically no creek a baronet oh no
public save a carton and atrocities in
district medical official committee
public worship or any belief that which
carries operative Amaravati will recent
m-maggie see cara mia pub at the Chateau
de the actually casting agent
mosquitoes carry the disease so all it
takes is one bite and a person can
become infected
however the disease has a period where
it's a hundred percent treatable and the
key is getting the medication that cures
it to people early but it's an uphill
battle and for many it's already too
late
the meriones a Polish economy sumatra it
a triple a hundred the katamari gammad
looked hip high lady a guru bj he
position Ameri me again aw that little
teeny integrity on each eye but change
is happening and rates of infection
across India are decreasing Hamlet is a
master Kim soosan of Akira cosmos our
local Aditi maximum longer delay may
11th ESS take cases I'm opening a
dehydrator
I'm cookin camlock Taj an apartheid in /
gamma dawn apart i sued haru before i
basura y mq botticella PA APNIC on me
[Music]
you
[Music]